we talked to you a bit about how I
relearned my entire design craft through
the process of entrepreneurship to do
that I'm going to take you back a bit I
remember exactly where I was on July 14
2002 it was my 31st birthday but that's
not why it sticks in my mind a six my
mind because it was the beginning I know
now of a 10 year personal Odyssey for me
in the beginning of one of the largest
steepest learning curves I've had the
opportunity to climb I was here more
specifically I was down there in the
basement conference rooms at the
Universal Sheraton in Los Angeles it was
the largest gathering of sex product
manufacturers in North America perhaps
the world welcome to the adult novelty
Manufacturers Expo I'm a designer and I
had just recently kicked off by an
independent design consulting firm the
weirdest thing happened three different
people unrelated potential clients came
to me and all asked me about the same
thing what about some sex products at
first I was a bit taken aback and I was
kind of skirting around the outside of
the conference hall because in the
middle of it was all the stuff you'd
imagine big dildos vibrators porn stars
the whole thing the price at that time
were frightening to look at had porn
stars in the packaging made audacious
claims that they couldn't actually
deliver on their made-up toxic materials
and overall poor user experience
sex is incredibly intimate incredibly
important and it's a fundamental aspect
of the human experience
to me intuitively as a designer it
seemed that if anything should be
beautifully designed and made and
presented its those products that engage
our sexuality so I started sketching and
then I launched a company and I called
that company
Jimmy Jane I raised money from friends
and family when I say friends and family
I mean my high school buddies very brave
and my mom who put in money so the first
product that we launched a little
something and actually there was a
collection around this but this is the
only vibrator in that first collection
this was designed to be completely
opposite from everything else that had
come before and to make a very big
statement about the possibilities in
this category it is made out of medical
grade materials rather than being toxic
here you see it in 24 karat gold
platinum and steel it was also silent
essentially everlasting because it has a
replaceable motor and so by pretty much
every metric it was moving in the
direction of I believe a better user
experience fast-forward many years and
today Jimmy Jane is a leading premium
sex products brand and we're launching
constantly top-selling category defining
products into this market they'll let me
take you back to 2007 a couple of years
after starting a company to share a
turning point and some lessons I learned
from it in 2007 we had just launched
this product form six it was a new
flagship for us and the core technology
was cordless charging and that meant
that this was the first fully
submersible rechargeable vibrator think
about the number of electronics that you
have that are rechargeable and
submersible there aren't many we weren't
just changing the technological sort of
context and the design and so on we're
also changing the retail context this
was selling at the sharper image at the
time sharper image was the top retailer
of massagers in the United States it was
also this product the number one premium
massager in that category in that store
but that wasn't the only place we were
selling we were breaking down barriers
all over the place we were selling
through Louie Vuitton
the private member's Club in Tokyo we
were selling through Nordstrom
Selfridges Sephora Fred Segal in LA Bed
Bath & Beyond W Hotels worldwide some of
these remain our partners to this day
and we did change that media context
where this conversation around sexuality
was happening we were the first and in
many cases the only brand still to have
been featured in publications like w LT
Q Esquire Wired we were on the Today
Show finally formed six making this big
splash we got what was very important to
me personally and my ego Design Awards
this is what we look for this is how I
know this is how I knew I was doing my
job well other designers saying good job
perhaps no where is the business value
of design more apparent than in the
context of a start-up in a start-up
you're starting from essentially a
baseline of zero there's nothing there
so everything you create you can see the
effect likewise there's a very strong
signal to noise ratio there's not a
whole lot else going on in the business
so there aren't all these other effects
compounding and making it difficult to
understand the effect so the cause and
effect is very easy to correlate on the
flip side of that know where are the
business risks of design more
potentially costly or even fatal behind
the scenes form six launch was an
operational and financial catastrophe it
was enormously complex to ramp up into
manufacturing and as a result it was
eight months behind in terms of its
launch four hundred percent over budget
he was selling for almost no margin we
were behind on our projections behind
our deliveries we were burning bridges
with our partners the company was
technically bankrupt this is why when we
took it into manufacturing it was almost
impossible to go through the final step
there was light at the end of the tunnel
though because we were just on the verge
one signature away from closing our next
round of financing at that exact moment
those investors got cold feet
understandably and they walked away we
weren't standing on the edge of the
cliff we were off the edge of the cliff
looking down and it was a long long
way down to make matters a little bit
worse for me personally I was also
essentially bankrupt I had invested all
of my personal savings and then quite a
bit more into the company even before we
really raised our first round of
financing compounding this further the
sharper image was soon to go bankrupt we
didn't know this yet but a couple months
later they would go bankrupt we'd never
be paid for the single-largest
order we had ever received let's not
even talk about the stock market crash
of 2008 so just at this moment of Jimmy
Jane's imminent demise I met a wise man
an entrepreneur and a seasoned one and
he said to me Ethan do you know the
first rule of starting a company and
clearly I did not know he said don't die
now the vast majority of startups break
this rule and I'm here to talk about a
particularly tragic cause of sudden
start-up death which I refer to as
design suicide we've heard a lot about
what designers can bring to
entrepreneurship but not nearly enough I
think about what entrepreneurship brings
to designers design is not a panacea it
cannot save your business indeed design
can kill it so let me share a couple of
lessons for my own attempts at design
suicide this is actually an image of
Jimmy Jane form - I'd ask you to raise
your hand if you have a form - but I'm
there you go boom okay we have a winner
the rest of you are lying it's a great
product I designed it with with eat
Bihar who you just saw so ran to a
manufacturing challenge with with one of
my first projects and that boss the time
came over and said to me looked all I
was doing and he said you need to smell
more plastic and what he meant by that
is that until I spent more time on the
factory floor I wouldn't really
understand the impact of what I was
doing on page what impact that would
have on the actual factory and the
production process and so on and he was
absolutely right when I designed form 6
in such a way that as the final step of
the manufacturing process we took
essentially a completely finished
product all the electronics everything a
lithium-ion battery put it back into an
injection mold an extremely high
pressure and it's
the high temperature inject liquid
silicone over it
somehow not causing the battery to
explode it was going to crush about 15%
of those meaning we had an extremely low
manufacturing yield all those costs need
to be loaded back into the other
products that you do get out of the
process for us this was nearly fatal so
smell the plastic and in the broader
sense what this means is for me I was
oblivious of all the various steps
needed between myself and the end-user
I was very familiar at that point with
the development path line but not with
all of the other interconnections into
the rest of the business we should all
know as designers when I sketch this
line
I just took saved 5% on the margin
that's a good thing when I sketched this
line the warehouse guys got to work an
extra day over the weekend and Waze gets
this line now we need a new
certification just to sell into Japan
next lesson many of you have seen this
before I'm guessing probably from people
who want you to do something good but
neither cheap nor fast so the idea here
is if you want something cheap and good
it's not gonna be fast if you want
something fast and good it's not gonna
be cheap designers like myself want it
to be good good good the designer and me
wants perfection with form six my
instinct was the better I make this
product the better the company will be
obviously as a result form six was slow
extremely expensive and incredibly good
stirrups demand a different definition
of perfection fast and cheap our
requirements they are non optional time
is money money is finite without money
you die so here's a different approach
that I took with a later program we had
a lot of traffic coming to Jimmy jenkum
or e-commerce site but a very low
conversion rate people were coming not
necessarily buying why I had a couple of
theories one there either looking for
something that they know and that's
familiar to them and they're not finding
it or two they're looking for something
that's less expensive than what we're
selling
so let's design a product know let's go
out and find all the iconic vibrators
that everybody knows
well test them to be to our standards
and then we will get them exclusively in
white package them together into a line
and call them the usual suspects we
designed essentially nothing this was
fast matter of a couple of months it was
cheap basically only the cost of the
inventory but was it good the test went
well in fact it went so well that these
products are still on sale on the Jimmy
Jane site today almost six years after
we launched the test I think we have the
conclusions of that test so choose two
it's a trick question in the startup
environment fast and cheap is good so we
were back in business
Jimmy Jane continued to grow but we
realized that we were addressing a bit
of a niche and that niche was the very
high-end we need to grow to reach a
larger audience to have broader
distribution we really needed an
affordable crowd crowd-pleaser in our
line so the designer me says design an
opportunity what can we create rather
than going for wholesale innovation we
turn to this this which did not design
is a fingertip vibrator these are very
well known in the market goes on your
finger and then you can imagine the rest
so you'll find these in your supermarket
they have a great promise right the idea
here is we all know how to explore and
touch and connect with our hands and our
fingers what if we put something on a
fingertip so that now that sensation is
amplified great idea but they weren't
delivering on that promise in fact they
were bulky and cumbersome so he could
not move naturally wasn't natural at all
and our testers told us the vibration
was insufficient so good idea of bad
execution we asked ourselves can we
deliver on this promise for real we
decided we thought we could so we
focused very narrowly on one thing and
that one thing was how do we get as much
power out of a small space as possible
after a lot of engineering work we ended
up with these vibration pods which
deliver three times the power in one
third the volume what that does is that
gives you a product that well you can
wear very naturally on the hand it's
intuitive it turns natural touch
into supernatural sensation your hands
are unencumbered so your hands can
wander as hands I want to do it's great
for couples just as an FYI we call this
product hello touch and it's been
welcoming consumers to the brand ever
since we launched it in the beginning of
2013 now unlike forum 6 this launched on
time on budget and with great margins in
fact it recouped all of its development
costs within the first 6 months of sales
so the idea here is this new not
necessarily better designers have an
innovation bias we feel often if we
don't put something in front of you that
you haven't seen before we're not doing
our jobs thing to know though is that
newness and business impact aren't
necessarily correlated what is
correlated is newness and risk with
newness comes unknowns with unknowns
come risk startups are already risky
enough they don't need designers adding
more on top of that so innovate
judiciously from entrepreneurs and
entrepreneurship I've learned countless
lessons about design I can boil almost
all of these down to one simple visceral
understanding and that is this we need
to in order to bring the most value to
startups and the users that they serve
keep the business impact top of mind
throughout the process we can then
design the experience and then get down
to the product but without that we're
really not designing in such a way that
it's sustainable for the company itself
I'm very proud of the impact that Jimmy
Jane and the Jimmy Jane team have had on
the sex products industry in fact today
this X proc products industry looks a
lot more like Jimmy Jane than it did
before it's a lot less a lot fewer toxic
products a lot better representation and
a very different mentality around this
and the conversation has opened up now
Jimmy Jane can't claim sole credit for
that but I think we've had a huge impact
several months after the launch of Hello
touch we were approached by a potential
acquirer after that acquisition I had to
decide what to do next and I knew what
that was just didn't know the format yet
I knew that I needed to leverage
design in the creation of new businesses
on an ongoing basis I refer to that as
venture design and today I am the head
of venture design at frog a global
design firm there I leverage our
capabilities our experience and our
reach and are almost 600 people in the
service of entrepreneurs and we make
investments in the form of services into
companies to date we've collaborate with
five founding teams to propel their
businesses forward always focusing on
designing the impact two quick examples
of what this might look like we were
approached earlier this year by two
entrepreneurs Bill Gross and Steve
Schell they count the cofounders of idea
shaper they came to us with a big vision
consumer printer 3d printers for all
essentially and they wanted to do this
with one the most affordable printer at
$279 retail and to it being the easiest
to use because of a system of an
ecosystem of also apps and great 3d
content for printing they came with this
prototype which demonstrates one of the
engineering solutions that they had that
is enabling their lower price they had a
very specific business objective and
working with us they had money what they
needed to do was to actually jumpstart
their ecosystem they needed both printer
owners and content providers to begin
working together as a community that to
build their ecosystem without the the
content why do you need a printer
without the printer
what do you can do with the content we
did a six-week sprint with them
collaborate closely honed their strategy
renamed and rebranded the company to new
matter
we designed the first iteration of the
physical product the digital marketplace
and apps then capture the whole story in
a video portion of what you're seeing
here which we launched on IndieGoGo for
their crowdfunding campaign the
IndieGoGo campaign was a wild success
the new matter is the number one 3d
printer on IndieGoGo but most
importantly we achieved the impact that
they were looking for we jump-started
that community they needed by pre
selling over 2,500 printers and getting
those out into the world and engaging a
huge audience of content providers to
now begin creating content for those
printers I'll leave you with this
both designers and entrepreneurs like to
reframe every challenge as an
opportunity that's both a designer and
an entrepreneur the opportunity that I'm
pursuing is summarized this way I
believe that through design we launch
stronger startups I'm a big proponent of
that and I think that many are but I
think there's another component to this
which is we through entrepreneurship
also become better designers ourselves
I'd like to see us spin up this virtuous
cycle and as much as possible minimize
the design suicides and design
fatalities along the way thank you very
much